I was looking at a lot of different
schools that had creative writing
programs and religious studies programs
as well and there are there are a fair
amount of those all over the country but
you know they're sort of spread out and
and i came across Carnegie Mellon and
saw what a fantastic undergraduate
writing program that they have and I
really just felt like I belonged here so
it was really an easy decision to make
once I got in to the school it's
interesting already having left Carnegie
Mellon thinking about what am I going to
do with mind my degree how am I going to
have an impact on the world because I
think being here you really you get the
impression that you can do anything
basically and what you do can have a lot
of weight and importance and even if
while you're here you're maybe not
working on anything that's particularly
groundbreaking a ton of other people are
so there's a really great example being
set to see you know you see other
undergraduates and graduate students and
just making huge waves in projects or
papers or plays they're putting on lots
of different things and so I think in
general it just makes me see how I can
take what I've learned here and and have
an impact on the world you know it will
probably be through my writing but it
could be through you know community
organizing or or someone I meet or my
travel having only been graduated for a
few months and living in San Francisco I
already see that there's an amazing
community of people there and you know I
think at a lot of other schools you
might meet someone that you went to
college with and you didn't know them
there but you say oh what class were you
and I was this class and there's
something in common there but you know
it seems to me that having gone to
Carnegie Mellon marks you in this
different way and and there's just a
stronger bond and then a lot I imagine
it a lot of other places because of sort
of what what people go through here in
terms of the rigor of the course load
and and also the the culture and the
traditions in my commencement speech i'm
going to talk about the atypical nature
of carnegie mellon students how we sort
of defy expectations and explanations
all of these and maybe stereotypes that
people have about us or or what we come
in with and and I share I'll share an
anecdote about finding a copy of the
last lecture in India actually in South
India translated into
malayalam which is a language that I
definitely don't know and and so there's
a bit of that talking about that global
reach the Carnegie Mellon has and also
and just the really amazing things that
students do here that aren't necessarily
overlooked but I think this is like a
really wonderful time to highlight them
and to celebrate our achievements and
sort of already having been gone for a
few months I can look back and say you
know this experience of going to
Carnegie Mellon will really will stay
with you you'll have these connections
these friends for for so long and
already I can see that now